hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dark cut 3 the last
chapter in the series of gruesome
surgery simulators that aren't quite
surgeon simulator and big warning again
it's going to be bloody and it's going
to get horrifying and people are gonna
be screaming in pain a lot it's gonna be
really really nasty but hey that's what
dark cut is and that's what you guys
wanted you want the chaos you want the
blood raining from the sky you're kind
of sadistic but I like it in a weird way
holy crap good god I'm recording did you
need some oh that really got me like it
was like five nights at Freddy's like
just bonnie slid into the window out of
nowhere like holy [ __ ] bayern boy okay
so back into the game now if you if
you're a little confused I am - because
I did not expect that at all Aaron
egoraptor just walked into the window in
front of me and just decided to say hi
while I was recording but either way
here we go we're back into it um god
that is a lot of surgeries what do I
need to do where do i click oh okay here
we go whoa that is a lot of things okay
soldier lost a finger and is bleeding
profusely wait is this like Assassin's
Creed where it's you're playing in the
whoa oh I'll bleep the patient what does
this even mean how did I get here what
did I miss
okay health is bad where's the booze
scan find missing bone fragments oh my
goodness
oh well there's some
I already started what the hell is going
on
oh it's bloody okay alrighty then what
did I do wrong
ok extract the remaining fragments and
put them on the tray got it
taught it close up the injury this isn't
even all that severe he died it wasn't
even that severe I didn't even get a
chance to do anything God everything got
thrown off from the beginning of this
game I had no idea what I'm doing
anymore ok right there ok I linked to
the patient apparently I don't have any
booze to give this guy so he's just
gonna have to tough it through I hate to
do that to him but hey times are tough
back in warriors I suppose yeah I know -
it's got to be more quickly about this
close that up can't see thank you there
we go oh I got a reattach his finger
what is this machine he's dead again how
do I give him more painkillers he's just
gonna keep dying on me over and over
again this is crazy here we go
okay there we go I guess I'm done I was
two steps away from being done and I
didn't even know it okay I guess I guess
that's just the way it is John Martin
went on to survive the first world war
he was awarded the Purple Heart and was
granted a period to revisit his two
daughters and wife
great I did it I'm the freakin
Assassin's Creed of surgery I think uh
how does this power feel I don't know I
didn't you now have the ability to bring
people back to life what life will they
live who will they love oh my god are
you kidding me if not for each other
this wouldn't be possible wait so we
both want to do great things and remake
history again am I going back in time
good luck human one did time travel have
anything to do with this I've no baby
what's happening okay I guess I move on
now nurse has lost leg to grenade well
great why do I need to worry about that
oh oh were you still saluting even when
you were on the ground
wow that's dedication right there okay I
gotta be quick about cleaning the leg
area
oh no oh do I have to amputate oh okay
yeah cuz this is how casts were made I
don't know what the hell that is
supposed to be god dammit I don't have a
default Oh God this balls I'm not doing
it fast enough I'm in too much shock
I'm not meant out to be a doctor I
couldn't say oh here's the sedate button
I didn't know that I just shot that into
the ground how did that help anyone at
all okay I'm gonna sedate more because
obviously I was not I was
clear on the instructions of this I was
distracted it was not my fault I didn't
do anything wrong okay let me just wipe
this off with a rag this leg will be
good as new though it wasn't in the dirt
or anything what are you talking about
and we're done what that's it when the
Ross field managed to survive the trench
experience also experiencing many
post-traumatic syndromes and permanent
leg injuries she has managed to recover
enough to enjoy the best of life has to
offer oh you know the best of all those
war times whatever wasn't all that bad
amazing isn't it yeah the very lives you
safe maybe of the unfolding of others
did you ever stop and think about who
you're saving no it's with nurse and a
guy what if these survivors go and kill
others now they went to their families
looks like more than one Jean line is
getting argumented argumented this is
good luck human is this my Jean line am
i saving my own ancestors where as
Assassin's Creed I just killed all my
ancestors or whatever I don't remember
guy Meadows this treatment is only
available in armored game stock up damn
it
well whatever fine I'll move on to other
things then okay soldier writes his
final words Joseph Francis Stalin okay
here we go uplink to patient give him
lots of drugs when you can't have
alcohol for your surgeries you'd be lots
of drugs I see that's a direct parallel
that's that's entirely true you
definitely do need lots of drugs okay oh
dear love we make for Virginia this
morning by nightfall we will engage the
enemy I will be safe I will be swift you
got it I'm trying to try to pull this up
okay come on our first night was
incredibly successful on the enemy has
withdrawn we're celebrating our
victories tonight you know it's kind of
its kind of detrimental to my cause here
to read these notes we have taken heavy
casualties tell Mark's wife is son has
been injured oh he is being sent home
tomorrow
oh no my son yesterday our encampment
was devastated by the coats I'm writing
from an abandoned farmhouse I hope I
find my commander goddamn how long is
this whatever the hell I'm pulling out
of him
sorry I just injected that note a little
bit looked like it was in a lot of pain
your love this is the last letter I can
write to you I'm minutes away from the
front line and I fear my life is about
to rest I am sorry I cannot see our son
I'm sorry I cannot come for you I prayed
to God this message finds its way to you
I've fallen in battle and no one can
help me my life is at an end
I love you I'm sorry I can not if I have
anything to say about it
Joseph Francis indeed saw his wife again
and retold his story of a mysterious
healer arriving in the darkest moments
his battle wounds sent him home but the
war for independence was won this was
the life he meant till husband was meant
to lead okay cool what what set it
astray I wish I could understand love
they're not compute
why love makes sense we bring peace
people back which mends broken hearts
right if only they knew what lives they
would have had in store we are the only
ones who would have knew good luck human
okay still not entirely sure I'm down to
clown with whatever the hell is going on
here okay soldier on a submarine has
sustained shoulder damage Oh boohoo mark
Tori deal with it Oh a little bit of a
shoulder ache oh well that's not a
little shoulder damage that's a long
shot where did this come from all right
whatever
this is uplink into him hey I got ejecta
pull drew
everyone needs mortars I don't think
that then I don't think that was in the
instruction set at all ah another pulley
Audi surgery I had that there we go okay
well if someone could hold on to the
lights and if the oppor man could just
pause for a little bit I'm kind of
needing to concentrate here I don't want
to be rude okay alarm why okay it's
nothing then oh okay I needs more
sedation why in this one specific spot
what doesn't make any sense none of this
makes any sense I'm just gonna carry on
my wayward son
what are these what what did I just put
twigs on him I just put a cloth and
twigs on him mark Tory managed to escape
the submarine not a moment too soon
moments after being impaled he managed
to get up and escape the sinking sub
meanwhile clutching a once punctured
shoulder saving people is amazing these
emotions I am experiencing are beyond my
code I wish to free more Souls do you
want to as well I am merely the
facilitation and you are the doctor we
work hand in hand Partners in saving the
unfortunate I'm like plankton and she's
my computer wife good luck human I will
take luck computer ok I guess click to
logout was that what I'm supposed to do
because apparently I can't do these
surgeries because I'm on the wrong
website click the logout what do you do
oh no what are you doing I can't let you
do that Dave we're not done please do
not leave oh I can't allow that stop a
face negative consequence a did you just
cut me where are these coming from
where's all my drugs where's my booze
good golly ah what since what is this a
thing I have to do
okay alright then that's perfect no
thank you thank you that was a great
great great great thing to do computer
you're just the best okay
I know many of you probably want to see
those extra surgeries that were out
there and I know you do too so I'm gonna
go to the other website that where
apparently it's only available this
looks awesome but I'm not done yet
oh okay here's the first of the bonus
surgeries that I didn't get to see and
it says and highlight I am thoroughly
happy to say this extreme pustules need
relieving really oh it looks like the
surface of Mars on am I gonna wipe that
off my face or am I just gonna oh that's
it oh oh
Meadows managed to recover after his
large bust you'll outbreak well good for
[ __ ] guy Meadows what the Frick
god damn it soompi sums people need just
the little help but unfortunately people
do not understand this one ounce of help
can amount to a lifetime of happiness
yeah someone just needed to come by and
slice open his boils he couldn't have
done that by himself leg bone broke skin
from fall now there's a surgery that's
what we need to do oh okay
no cruncher bunch no crunch a munch well
that's it I'm not gonna put him in a
cast or anything well that's it that's
all these bonus surgeries are Oh leg
bone injury was fixed successfully I
think they could have just gone to the
hospital you know doesn't seem like a
life-threatening situation a knife a
needleless syringe these are all merely
tools of the trade until you bring them
and your patient
life good luck human evidence alright
here's the third one
buzz McDonald s'en crash survivor unable
to move needs help removing ticks
removing ticks
well not the crash just the ticks oh
okay oh no he didn't want to let go he
was a saucy tick the trick is you got to
get like something hot to make him back
out cuz otherwise if you just pull them
off their head is gonna stay in there
and that's either gonna be a problem cuz
you're gonna roll around in your
arteries for a bit until it gets clogged
or it's just gonna be a head in your
skin it's gonna be weird he takes my dad
once took care of a tick he like took a
cigarette button back before he quit
smoking he bowed too close to and just
I'm a bum bum and then he pulled around
killed that story a good story everybody
huh while unable to help himself the
removal of ticks let him hold on to
precious life and survived wait that
might be reaching a little bit that
might be reaching just a little bit
there but hey it is what it is I saved
him one organ infecting another amazing
how creatures prey on others for
survival everyone shut up no ha ha they
take life away only to give it to
themselves
oh shut up shut up good luck you but
thank you computer
you fancy organism you oh look I found
the Easter Egg computers are so funny I
have put an easter egg in the game to
show how funny I am oh ho ho I will
laugh myself to sleep mode remember two
nine one two one two nine one two one
two nine one two one two nine one two
one two nine one two one say with me
everybody to nine one two one are you
saying at home I know you're not say two
nine one two one do not want to one two
nine one two one two nine one two one
two nine one two one two one one
do not want one two nine one one two
okay I actually have no idea what two
nine one two one is supposed to be like
in reference to so this was dark cut
three I'm pretty sure I explored just
about everything there was I think those
are just achievements on the end there
but hey this was fantastic I loved it J
MTB he makes fantastic games check out
some of his other stuff and if you want
to see me plays other stuff let me know
which ones you want down in the
description below
it's like achievement unlocked the other
one this is the only level a whole bunch
of stuff so let me know thank you again
everybody for watching and as always